[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité va nous faire découvrir le
monde de l'architecture il en est un
acteur majeur l'un des plus grands l'un
des plus connu et reconnu son nom est
associé à des édifices qui sont une
fierté nationale mais qui surtout et
c'est peut-être le principal pour lui
qui font la fierté des locaux des
habitants des villes concernées les
Nanta sont très fiers de leur gare par
exemple les exois de leur pavillon noir
les Parisiens de leur stade jamboin et
que dire alors de la fierté des
Marseillais devant le Musem Musée des
civilisations de l'Europe et de la
Méditerranée tout cela et bien plus
encore c'est lui et je parle des
habitants des gens des Français parce
que c'est d'abord à eux qu'il pensent
lorsqu'il conçoit un bâtiment il a
choisi ce métier en observant les maçons
les artisans les ouvriers sur les
chantiers bravant le froid le vent sans
protection parfois si je n'avais pas
senti l'odeur des matériaux la
sensibilité l'apreté du monde du travail
je ne serais pas l'architecte que je
suis devenu dit-il quel architecte
est-il devenu justement qu'est-ce qu'un
projet réussi à ses yeux quelle est sa
définition du beau posons-lui toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue à vous rudti merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
Sénat parlons de vos œuvres à vous j'ai
un peu évoqué quelques œuvres en
introduction
elles sont si différentes les unes des
autres alors il y a le Musem il y a le
musée jeancocto de Menton la
Philharmonie DEAT aussi est-ce que ces
œuvres vous ressemblent est-ce qu'elles
disent quelque chose de vous de l'homme
que vous êtes alors là je n'ai pas de
réponse à ça ce n'est pas mon objectif
je n'ai pas ce sens du miroir à ce à ce
pointl j'ai entendu dire souvent que
c'était le cas notamment par le fait que
je fais une architecture je revendique
une architecture plutôt féminine on le
voit dans le dernier projets que j'ai
fait pour Chanel à Paris à la porte
aubervidier on le voit dans le
département de art de l'Islam au Louvre
on le voit dans différents projets comme
la salle de de
ashtad hashtad à Berlin la
Philharmonique à Postdam il y a beaucoup
de de féminité je ve dire avec beaucoup
de un déficit d'humilité de grâce ouis
en son sens je dois avoir un côté un peu
femme c'est possible tout en étant
hétérosexuel de race blanche coupable à
fort accent avec un fciè méditerranéen
vous voyez mais féminité dans vos œuvres
c'est ça la ligne oui c'est c'est plutôt
ça malgré moi je je n'ai pas fait exprès
c'est sorti par l'exigence du travail
l'exigence sur les valeurs du labeur
vous
savez davantage l' exige de la matière
de ressources de
puissance davantage lacrimonier est
grande quand à la question esthétique
c'est-à-dire elle doit être légitime
fondée sur une immédiateté j'execre les
mots comme minimal conceptuel qui sont
l'apanage des feignants non mais
attendez attendez et vous c'est travail
hein votre ah c'est la vertu essentielle
le labeur et sa mémoire et l'ensemble
des métiers qui fabriquent ce labeur
voilà c'est quoi un bon architecte selon
vous ah non Jech an anxieux pourquoi
inquiet parce que j'aime phrase d'un
économiste anglais qui disait tomorrow
only paranoiaac will survive demain seul
les paranoïques survivront pour être un
bon architecte il faut être d'abord
inquiet et ne pas voir la vérité là où
on croit qu'elle est elle est toujours
derrière elle est toujours ou devant ou
derrière le le factuel
elle est pas là donc un bon architè qui
veut survivre s'il veut pas prendre une
balle immédiatement il faut d'abord
qu'il réfléchisse à à qui il parle et
d'où il parle des apostrophe au u accent
d'où je parle et on parle toujours à
partir d'un territoire nourri voilà
l'architecte est au croisement
d'injonction souvent contraire on parle
du beau versus le pratique est-ce qu'on
est obligé de faire des compromis quand
on est architecte c'est le métier
lui-même qui est fait sur le compromis
avec cette nécessité d'en faire le moins
possible parce qu'il y a des
compromissions utiles à d'autres
néfastes les compromissions utiles sont
celles on essaie de d'économiser les
ressources par exemple c'est en
compromis avec la nature avec les
exigences du monde sû en tout les cas
dans mes projets il y a une économie de
matière surtout dans les derniers de
plus en plus d'où une certaine grâce une
fragilité une féminité mais à laquelle
je demande beaucoup d'effort come on le
fait avec les femmes les femmes sont
toujours convoquées à faire beaucoup
d'efforts peu reconnu porter des
fardeaux incroyables des des enfants
très lourds dans les bras non'ont pas la
charpente d'un parachutiste tout de même
vous voyez ah ben c'est un peu ça que
j'attends de cette architecture mais que
dire de plus chaque projet est différent
chaque projet est un contexte chaque
projet est une circonstance ce que je
trouve assez fou c'est que
l'architecture est un domaine assez peu
connu du grand public et reconnu par le
grand public alors que ça nous concerne
tous c'estàdire qu'on vit tous quelque
part on travaille tous quelque part à
priori en tout cas on on est censé tous
concernés par le bâtiment dans lequel
nous sommes et finalement j'ai j'ai le
senti qu' a une espèce d'ingratitude
vis-à-vis de l'architecte vous le
ressentez comme ça je le ressentais
comme ça mais je veux pas me plaindre je
pense qu'on est mal placé pour se
plaindre ou je pense que c'est un métier
très riche je suis pas là pour faire un
pldoyer syndicaliste mais évidemment
j'ai beaucoup à dire et d'ailleurs je le
dis dans des livres je le dis dans des
manifestations dans des conférenceces je
ramène ma grande gueule dans des lieux
publics pour défendre l'exercice de ce
métier dans certains livres
l'architecture un sport de combat l'exil
de la beauté enfin vous connaissez ma
littérature il y en a une dizaine euh
mais néanmoins on est encore privilégié
en France par rapport à d'autres pays
hein j'ai d'abord un document à vous
proposer c'est une archive délivrée par
nos partenaires les archives national il
s'agit d'un lotissement HLM réalisé dans
le cadre du concours international de la
maison individuelle en 1969 là on est à
cré près de Montpellier un ensemble de
235 maisons bien carrées bien alignées
je crois que vous avez vous-même réalisé
dans cette même dans les années 2010 le
HLM la Capitelle et vous avez dit un
jour imposer la Ledur en architecture
c'est mépriser le peuple est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'avec ce type de
grands ensembles qui ont été qui ont
foisonné à un moment donné de notre de
notre histoire est-ce qu'à ce moment là
on a méprisé le peuple avec ces grands
ensembles absolument mais c'était une
époque aussi où il n'y avait pas de
logement individuel il n y avait pas de
logement social donc les gens étaient
heureux d'avoir un lieu moi-même j'ai
découvert le confort dans un HLM qu
j'avais 4 5 ans avec un sol souple une
baignoire les radiateurs je trouve ça
formidable et d'autres copains qui
habitaent dans des quartiers qui n'était
pas du logement social venent chez moi
pour voir ma chambre avec un sol bleu
ils étaient estomaqués vous imaginez il
y avait pas d'ascenseur mais c'était un
luxe non ce qui est la la vraie il faut
bien essayer de décerner où est la
culpabilité derrière ça la culpabilité
ce ne sont pas que les architectes ce
sont les organismes de production de de
logement qui sont responsables ce sont
les administ tion territoriale qui qui
utilise ce type de composition urbaine
néfaste sans intelligente ce sont aussi
les architectes par souci d'économie
pourquoi d'après vous non alors par
souci d'économie j'aimerais bien par
souci de bonne conscience voyez de bonne
conscien comment est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à faire ça sans culpabiliser ben
je vais vous dire la totalité des
intervenants le maîre d'ouvrage l'élu
l'administration territoriale le
ministère de l'Équipement l'architecte
tout le monde est mouillé jusqu'à la
garde ce n'est pas la peine d'essayer d'
voir autre chose et même doctrinairement
ce sont les conséquences néfastes d'une
modernité
acculturée totalement accult il y a une
dizaine d'années téérama fait une
enquête sur ce que le magazine a appelé
à l'époque la France moche le
gouvernement a annoncé un grand
programme de transformation de cette
France moche de ces zones moches il y a
une urgence à se débarrasser de ces
zones industrielles de ces parkings de
ces espèces de c'est toute cet
environnement périphérique au villees
bien sûr c'est un territoire à
reconquérir d'abord c'est un territoire
avec une horizontalité par il y a rien
en élévation donc il n'y a pas
d'économie du sol il y a une
imperméabilisation du sol évidemment
c'est le c'est le babas mais il faut
avoir le courange de réformer les
documents d'urbanisme qui les qui les
définissent c'est là peut-être que ça
oui bien sûr il faut surdensifier sur
les bâtiments existants empiler des
activités des parkings en surface
enlever les parkings des parkings sur la
toiture enlever sur la surface pour
enlever le goudron planter des végétaux
ou même multiplier les activités par
empilement un message que vous envoyez
aux élus ici présents c que j' non non
un message que j'envoie aux
collectivités territoriales autant qu'à
notre administration nationale mais il
faut des réformes courageuses pour ça et
c'est peut-être ça qui manque dans notre
pays des réformes courageuses parce queà
part des injonctions contradictoires à
dire il ne faut pas il faut pas
imperméabiliser le sol mais il faut pas
monter en hauteur H mais il y a pas
d'autre solution que la dépression
nerveuse comprenez ça l'un de l'une de
vos nombreuses particularités c'est
d'être un adepte du béton vous en avez
fait même un texte un manifeste le béton
en garde à vue je vous cite un matériau
à qui je parle et qui me parle parce
qu'il est prévenant attentionnez à
l'image d'une bonne mè vous dénoncez
d'ailleurs le procès qui est fait au
béton jugé par certains trop
consommateurs en sable et vous répondez
le béton a une empreinte
environnementale 80 fois inférieure à
celle de l'acier et de 200 fois à celle
de l'aluminium ça veut dire que le béton
c'est encore l'avenir d'abord on ne fait
plus le béton comme on le faisait dans
les années 30 et qu'effectivement
l'empreinte environnementale s'est
considérablement effondrée enfin réduite
pardon et que on a quelques industriel
dont en France quelques uns dont un qui
fait un béton avec une empreinte
environnementale nulle et la réponse
n'est pas sur le matériau lui-même c'est
sur l'économie qu'on en a et les le
ramener à une équation dans laquelle la
distance entre le lieu de production et
le lieu de consommation doit être le
plus courte possible et la durée de vie
après pour faire comprendre
ça aux écolos ircibl c'est difficile
parce qu'il faut une culture
technoscientifique comme com le problme
c'est qu'on parle à tort et à travers
aujourd'hui le béton est le matériau le
plus socialisé c'est le matériau qui
défend une mémoire de proximité c'est le
matériaux qui défend aussi des
savoir-faire qui accumulé font une
richesse territoriale et c'est une un
matériau qui n'est pas spéculatif
contrairement au coton au chocolat à la
vanille au pétrole au gaz voyez-vous il
faut avoir un peu de jugement et être un
peu moins irraciible sur ça mais c'est
vrai que dans un pays qui est de moins
en moins commandé euh comment dire
ordonné ordré sur le désir du travail
peut-être que ça devient suspect mais de
manière générale vous êtes très en
colère contre le discours écologiste
antibéton je vous cite vous parlez d'un
anéantissement idéologique et imprudent
du béton le béton c'est une famille
d'emploi de métier qui partage un savoir
il faut de la bienveillance pour le
béton dites-vous l'écologisme va devenir
le trempelin du fascisme ouis il y a une
grande colère en vous non
attendezocation non il y a pas de
provocation je le pense ouis j'ai une
idée très noble de de la question
environnementale et
écologique et je pense d'ailleurs que le
futur du monde comme laboratoire de
pensée sera plutôt le monde rural que le
monde urbain pour accélérer la pensée
et que je vois avec plaisir en lisant la
presse ce matin que dans un groupement
des pays là le
G20 la plupart des pays vont relancer la
question nucléaire notamment dans des
formats plutôt réduits ouais à petite
échelle évidemment pour trouver des
alternatives au charbon et cetera et il
faut quand même bien réaliser que
lorsqu'on fait venir une charpente bois
de Pologne pour aller à Perpignan et qui
a je sais pas 1500 km à traverser sur
une char très légère parce que le bois
flotte sur un poids lourd qui n'est pas
chargé à bloc de ses capacités
l'empreinte environnementale elle est
désastreuse mais personne veut voir il y
a des par idéologie par idéologie par
dénis mais surtout par incompéten
technique et scientifique et je vous le
dis c'est ça que vous mettez en avant
c'est l'exper seulement le béton la
meilleure emprte printe environnementale
de tous les matériaux et ça se discute
même avec le bois ça se discute même le
bois sur les conditions fr action de
transport depuis les syriies des
centaines de kilomètres et cetera mais
en plus encore une fois le à la la
défense cette condition sociale d'une
mémoire collective voilà et d'être et
d'être aussi fiscalisé en France
territorialement vous voyez c'està-dire
ben d'être assujetti à l'ensemble des
règlements qui font la santé d'une
république c'est-à-dire la fiscalité la
santé voz le droit social oui parce que
ça ça vient pas de ça vient pas du
tirmond
contrairementcoup de maté qui AR je ne
sais d' voyez vous êtes aussi en colère
contre je suis pas en colère je suis
vivant oui donc c'est très bien c'est
une façon d'être VI j'aime tellement mon
pays la France je veux en défendre tout
ce qui fait l'intelligence voilà mais
alors en tout cas ça vous met en colère
ce qui vous met en colère c'est le
harcèlement bureaucratique ce sont vos
termes vous dites il y a 30 ans il
fallait 3 mois pour instruire un permis
de construire de nos jours ça peut aller
jusqu'à 1 an et la masse documentaire à
fournir a été multipliée par 100 la sur
réglementation a atteint un niveau
hystérique est-ce que ça vous fait même
dire que peut-être le métier
d'architecte est menacé par tout ça par
ses injonctions écolo par ces
injonctions administratives c'est
l'intelligence du métier qui est menacé
je parle avec des jeunes confrères tout
neuf là la trentaine ils sont déjà
désespérés avant de commencer leur
métier parceil savent pas comment s'y
prendre mais c'est pareil en médecine
lorsque je parle avec un médecin ils me
disent c'est la même chose il y a une
une hystérie une masse réglementaire
dont on se demande
quel est le fond dont on pourrait tenter
d'imaginer qu'elle a pour oiget de
cristalliser le fonctionnement ou la
lecture démocratique du dispositif mais
ce n'est pas vrai c'est en fait une
bureaucratie quand même qui a été
inventée par Napoléon pour fluidifier et
garantir le le modèle démocratique bravo
Napoléon sauf que ça se retourne contre
nous maintenant ça se transforme comme
un virus un virus qui se transforme le
voyez le virus du sida par exemple qui s
transformé plusieurs fois de sorte que
la bureaucratie a compris qu'en
fabriquant de la nuisance elle
renouvelle son territoire existentiel
voilà vous conseill don dont elle-même
est victime il suffit simplement de
parler avec des gens qui partent dans
des administrations territoriales ils
sont désespérés ils vivent de
l'intérieur le monstre qu'ils ont
eux-même créé alors c'est pas c'est pas
un discours plaintif droitier c'est
juste un discours si on aime son pays on
doit le dire on doit dire les choses
mais vous conserz un jeune de se lancer
dans en architecture aujourd'hui ou pas
bien s bien malgré tout ça malgré tout
ça attendez s' qu'est-ce qu'il lui
faudrait à ce jeune qui se lance en
architecture aujourd'hui une bonne santé
d'abord bonne santé psychique il lui
faut il lui faut du
cœur faire fonctionner un peu la
cervelle et et du ventre un peu de
l'estomac voilà par que vous avez obtenu
de de très nombreux prix he des
distinctions très prestigieuses le grand
prix national de l'architecture en 2006
le Grand Prix spécial du jury de l'Éc
d'argent est-ce que la France se
distingue dans le monde sur le plan
architectural est-ce qu'on a de bons
architectes vous évidemment mais est-ce
que globalement la France se distingue
oui je peux vous dire j'ai fait de
nombre j'ai dû faire peut-être 200
conférences dans le monde ouais pour moi
c'est clair les bons architectes sont
français que ça vous plaise ou pas de
l'entendre c'est comme ça je dire malgré
la médiocrité de la pédagogie parce que
les enseignants sont pas au niveau du
métier sont souvent des gens démunis
ils ont cette paranoïa les étudiants en
architecture cette capacité à se relever
à devenir des combattants
instinctivement parce que très vite ils
comprennent que tout est tordu tout est
voilé ils savent qu'il faut y aller
qu'il faut mettre les mains dans la
partie obscure de la matière pour savoir
de quoi elle elle parle et pour
l'attraper et la saisir vous voyez et
donc c'est super c'est plein d'espoir ce
que vous
dites non non non je peux vous dire j'ai
je renouvelle quand mon cabinet il a 42
2 ans
d'existence 43 ans euh j'ai toujours de
jeunes architectes inexpérimentés qui
viennent chez moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que en quelques mois ça devient des
vrais cavaliers voyez des des des des
fantassins je sais pas quand des
combattants je suis très très surpris
parce que c'est l'inquiétude qui les
gouverne c'est un métier où il n'est pas
nécessaire de faire de psychanalyes vous
êtes le miroir ce que vous faites c'est
votre propre miroir ouais on pcher sur V
sur votre histoire personnelle un petit
peu parce que ça fait partie des rituels
de cette émission vous êtes un
méditerranéen 100 % né en Algérie
famille d'origine italienne aujourd'hui
installé à Cassie vous êtes très vite au
contact des métiers de construction au
travers de votre père qui était maçon au
départ qui avait quitté l'école à l'âge
de 12 ans et qui a fini directeur
général d'une entreprise inscrit à
l'Ordre des architectes un homme qui
s'est fait tout seul vous non plus ce
n'est pas grâce à l'école que vous avez
réussi vous étiez un très mauvais élève
dites-vous vos propos sont d'ailleurs
assez dur sur vous-même ça m'a ça m'a
frappé vous dites j'étais médiocre en
tout j'avais redoublé mon CM2 j'étais
programmé pour l'échec je n'avais aucune
estime de moi-même je me sentais
inexistant j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
difficile ces propos sur soi c'est
vraiment ce que vous ressentez comme
malgré les apparences c'est toujours un
peu comme ça il j'ai des grands moments
de de
dégringolade de confiance Saturne de
type saturnienne je dire je je c'est pas
la perte de c'est pas la perte de
courant c'est pas la perte de confiance
c'est la perte d'estime de soi-même euh
au d' moment je me trouve extrêmement
lâche je me trouve très très lâche ouais
euh lâche par rapport à des phénomènes
sociaux je sens que certains devant
certaines adversités je n'ai pas le
courage je pense à ceux qui défendent la
France je pense aux combattants qui
défensent la France je pense à à nos
jeunes policiers qui se prennent des des
trucs enflammés dans la gueule voyez
pour le SMIG je pense à c'est fils du
peuple comme disait pierre Paolo
pazolini non qui sont là pour défendre
la santé l'éducation voilà le plaisir de
Vire ensemble vous êtes devenu officier
supérieur au sein de la réserve
citoyenne vous avez écrit manifeste
légionnaire 88 pas minutes au service de
la démocratie vous dites d'ailleurs je
ne supporte plus l'antimilitarisme de
bistro mais vous êtes sur le terrain
vous êtes ah oui je je suis très très
fier d'appartenir à cette cette armée
d'élite qui est la Légion étrangère don
je suis effectivement lieutenant colonel
et vous joignez la parole au oui oui oui
qui sont des gens où honneur et fidélité
sont majeurs et depuis que je les côtoi
pouvez pas savoir le bonheur le bonheur
que c'est d'être avec des gens qui ont
des valeurs des valeurs des valeurs en
amitié des valeurs en solidarité ils
sont pour
moiage avec 150 nationalités différentes
culture religion race langue mémoire
est-ce que vous imaginez ce qui est le
partage ces gens qui ont besoin et qui
ont le droit après avoir eu une enfance
souvent une jeunesse chaotique chaotique
méprisée fait de souffrance qui ont le
droit à une seconde vie et la France le
ramène ça avec Solidarité si je poursuis
le fil de votre histoire vous allez être
très vite fasciné parce que vous voyez
au contact de ces chantiers de ce
travail manuel par le courage là aussi
de ces ouvriers c'est décidé une valeur
qui revient souvent chez vous ça a été
un déclic ça a été un tournant de
d'observer ces ces ouvriers sur les
chantiers c'est là que vous vous dites
je les voyais un peu comme des cowboys
avec le marteau à la ceinture j'étais
émerveillé ou oui j'étais j'étais
émerveillé devant la baraque de chantier
de mon père où il était chef j'entendais
mon père vociférer voilà c'était
l'époque je devais avoir donc je devais
avoir à peine même pas 10 ans vous voyez
ouais voilà oui oui j'ai toujours vu ce
ce milieu comme espèce de de milieu
forestier et dans laquelle il y a plein
de
d'animaux plus ou moins sauvages qui
sont à l'intérieur j'ai touj un peu
c'est peut-être un peu Alice au pays des
merveilles version masculin hein voilà
alors à l'âge de 12 ans vous rencontrez
aussi vous faites une rencontre
déterminante un certain Monsieur Jean un
comptable communiste qui vous donne des
cours de maths dans la cuisine de son
HLM à côté d'un frigo très très bruyant
dont vous vous souvenez encore et lui il
va bouleverser votre vie et votre regard
sur vous-même est-ce qu'il va vous
redonner confiance juste un peu je pense
qu'il a déclenché chez moi cette
paranoïa utile et nécessaire à ma survie
de cette façon là effectivement j'avais
je vais avoir 11 ou 12 ans j'étais nul
en tout évidemment inconscient que
j'étais nul en tout et puis il me il me
don des cours de géométrie d'algèbre il
me sort cette francee incroyable je
l'entends comme si c'était hier avec la
lampe auudessus de la NAP ciré dans la
cuisine dans son hlm Rudi la géométrie
et l'art de raisonner juste des figures
fausses ça m'a fait l'effet d'une balle
qui me traverse la boîte cranienne au
ralenti et je me suis dit dès ce jour-là
donc ce que je vois n'est pas la vérité
la réalité est ailleurs et cette idée de
de quête d'une réalité qui serait pas
celle porté par les mots par les signes
par les formes par les couleurs m' aidé
à à survivre dans le cursus de mes
études je lui dois l'ingénieur que je
suis l'architecte que je suis le grand
prix national membre de l'Académie des
technologies vous av l'asion de lui dire
bah il est mort et et je suis pas j'ai
cherché il n'avait pas d'enfant et lui
et sa femme ont donné leur corps à la
science j'ai là je réalise que c'était
un grand
humaniste je lui dois tout je pense que
je lui dois tout à la lueur de celui que
vous êtes aujourd'hui quel conseil
donneriez-vous au petit garçon qui se
lance dans la vie petit garçon petite
fille d'un la vie mais à quel âge vous
savez moi mes enfants je les ai éduqués
dans l'exigence de la beur hm hm j'ai
trois enfants je suis grand-père six
fois
euh et au village au village de 6000
habitants à bambol ils ont fait l'école
maternelle le collège l'école maternelle
le primaire le collège le lycée à
toulong et à l'arrivée des courses là où
on est dans un échec social phénoménal
vous comprenez la plage la mer les
bateaux euh lé il est ingénieur des pond
etchaussé spécialiste en mathématique
appliqué la 2uxème est avocat de droit
publi et le dernier est architecte
je me suis ils se sont pas trop mal
débrouillés et s'ils se sont pas trop
mal débrouillés alors que je n'avais pas
de temps à leur consacrer c'est qu'ils
avaient bien enregistré un message quand
même la culture du travail celui que je
leur disais je paye trop d'impôt je
payerai pas l'enseignement privé vous
êtes mal barré vous êtes provincial vous
avez l'accent un nom qui finit Paris ça
va être dur pour vous donc c'est pas la
peine d'attendre l'ascenseur sociale
vous allez prendre l'escalier ils ont
pris l' escalier ils ont créé tous les
trois leur métier ils en vivent très
bien voilà j'ai des photos pour vous
ridti
la première la voici je je je vous voyez
regardz ces photos avec méfiance vous
inquiétez pas ça va bien se passer alors
il s'agit de la Cité internationale de
la langue française à villercotteray
inaugurée par Emmanuel Macron chaque
président a tendance à a laissé son
empreinte dans le paysage on a eu
mitéran avec la BNF Chirac avec le musée
du kbranli comment expliquez-vous que
les présidents estent à ce point besoin
de marquer leur mandat ou l'histoire
avec un bâtiment avec de
l'architecture mais c'est une histoire
naturelle de de la civilisation
occidentale ça me paraît pas la marque
ben c'est pas forcément la marque d'un
ego d'un Patos je pense que que
l'architecture en tous les cas même pas
l'altitude du chef de l'État témoigne
pétrifie un moment politique esthétique
économique d'une société et que c'est
normal qu'un homme politique al surtout
le président
euh vous qui aimez les mots vous qui
aimez temp la langue française vous
auriez aimé le le le réaliser ce projet
alors je l'ai pas visiter ouais je
n'allais pas visiter je le connais pas
bien mais ça a l'air charmant il y a une
partie historique qui m'a l'air bien
conservée après ce que je vois pas bien
fais-toi voir je l'ai pas visité c'est
une verrière c'est ça oui oui non mais
c'est moi je trouve ça pas mal hein
ouais je tu es réussi je pas vu mais non
je peux pas dire que c'est pas bien
voilà une deuxième photo Fabien Roussel
patron du Parti communiste pour quel
vous avez voté au premier tour de la
dernière présidentielle vous dites
appartenir à la gauche RAC au sens
réactive à l'airire du temps ou
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire mais c'est
vrai j'ai voté Fabien rouss je n'avais
jamais voté communiste j'avais voté pour
lui parce que j'étais en voiture et je
l' entends dire qu'il était pour le
barbecue la chasse la
corrida et le nucléaire et là je dis ah
je dis de GO le grand retour j'ai voté
pour lui au parti communiste voilà et au
deuxième tour j'ai voté Macron j'ai une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
ce lieu Rudy richitotti nous sommes
entourés de quatre statues qui
représente chacune une vertu il y a la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence laquelle de ces vertus vous
parle le plus où vous caractérise alors
écoutez la sagesse certainement pas je
je ça me déprime la sagesse je trouve ça
complètement déprimant quoi c'est une
prétention quoi c'est c'est comme
l'humilité vous savez l'humilité n'est
que le masque de la vanité c'est William
Blake qui avait dit ça donc surtout pas
la sagesse je le laisse aux jeunes là
vous voyez la sagesse pour essayer
d'accélérer leur destin le plus rapide
vers la porte de secours vers la porte
de sortie la prudence ça me ressemble
absolument pas parce que je suis très
très pas non plus je suis très imprudent
et la justice et l'éloquence attends et
je vis dangereusement alors ce que
j'aime dans éloquence c'est l'exigence
linguistique c'est-à-dire on a une belle
langue le français et bon ben il faut
l'utiliser moi j'ai interdit dans mon
bureau qu'on utilise les termes anglais
par exemple les anglicismes ah ah ben
oui et puis je n'ai que mon mon bras
droit associé euh directeur d'agence qui
a autorisé à signer un courrier à ma
place parce qu'il sait écrire le
français très bien mais voilà dans dans
l'éloquence je retiens c'est l'amour de
la langue l'éloquence on s'arrête oui
comme au 19e siècle la bouclé bouclée
merci Ry richti d'avoir été avec nous
dans un monond un regard merci d'avoir
partagé ce moment avec nous et merci à
vous de nous avoir suivci comme chaque
semaine émission à retrouver en podcast
bien sûr à très vite sur public SNA
[Musique]
merci